[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you a great cast of
characters as well among them these a
young piano Prodigy with a talent you
gotta hear to believe also a 21 year old
with autism and a family business with
an important mission statement plus a
local hero who went above and beyond to
help a stranger stuck in the snow and in
dire need of help and watch me yes me
conquer my fears all that and our most
heartwarming videos the ones you just
need to see you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
okay
hey there I'm Tony decopal and this is
the uplift the show that lifts you up
for at least the next 30 minutes you and
me as well and we're going to begin with
an 11 year old boy with autism who
became known as a piano Prodigy because
of his Mozart level skills they earned
him a very big surprise here's Vlad
goutier thank you
to say this Colorado boy is a piano
Prodigy would not be enough
that's 11 year old Jude who has autism
one day he just sat down at the family's
electric keyboard and this is what came
out
Jude could listen to any music and
figure out how to play it immediately it
was this if he had been taking lessons
for years but Jude has a different
explanation I was inspired I was
inspired by God Jude was featured in a
local TV report which caught the
attention of professional piano tuner
Bill Magnuson saying Jude had Mozart
level Talent Magnuson used his father's
inheritance to buy the youngster a grand
piano and here it is arriving in the
family's home
[Applause]
an act of kindness that has changed his
life and that is coming from a whole
total stranger who never knew him but
just decided to help him in that grand
style yeah it's it's amazing yes Jude
and his father Isaiah kufi told us he
now plans to play every day and is
learning to read music I never stop
always on and on and on and on yeah
three hours a day a Divine Talent which
his family hopes will ensure him a
brighter future Vladimir YouTube CBS
News New York
I think they're right we're moving on
now to introduce you to a mom from
Georgia who wanted her daughter who has
autism to have a fulfilling life so
what'd she do well she created something
big very big for her here's Caitlin
O'Kane every morning 21 year old Jordan
Moore wakes up and goes to work at her
very own t-shirt company
she gets to the warehouse greets her
co-workers you need more shirts yeah
okay and then it starts packing up
orders
with an occasional dance break Jordan's
mom Jackie says working at her own
company is nothing short of a miracle
for Jordan because Jordan was born with
Autism and verbal apraxia if you listen
to a video of her you will quickly
notice that her speech is not typical
speech she has a very deep voice she
struggles to put her thoughts into words
but she did not speak until she was over
the age of six so when we hear her now
it's amazing how much she's able to say
Jordan continued to overcome challenges
but her parents still saw one on the
horizon we just kept finding there was
so little opportunity for an individual
like her once she got out of school and
it was really keeping my husband and I
up at night like what was she gonna do
about five years ago they started
Jordan's summer shirt project a way to
keep her busy during the summer while
also teaching her new skills the thought
of Jordan being able to independently
roll a T-shirt and add or wristband to
it without any help seemed like an
extremely lofty goal at that time she
was struggling to do much of anything
independently so when you're thinking
about that how was she going to find a
job and
um it was that summer that we set out
we're like you know what even if she has
to have someone help her that's okay
we're gonna set out to do the best she's
able to do
they sold t-shirts with a simple but
meaningful design be kind to everyone I
wanted our whole idea to have a greater
meaning and that's what led me to the
idea of kindness
um I originally started thinking of
getting the world to be kinder to
individuals with disabilities but when I
thought about it more I was like you
know what this world needs to be kinder
to everyone they found a solution to
their problem when Jordan graduated last
year she had the t-shirt business to
look forward to it would be good job
today yep you're doing a good job today
and on Tick Tock where they amassed two
million followers they give viewers the
behind the scenes of their operations
and teach them valuable lessons Jordan
went from people maybe not engaging with
her because they didn't know what to say
to her to suddenly being at the grocery
store or anywhere she goes and their
people are like there's Jordan from Tick
Tock and she just kind of glows and they
they talk about what she can do so you
went from a life of talking about your
struggles to suddenly everybody noticing
what you're good at what you're
accomplishing and it was just such an
eye-opener for me that
I think everybody wants to be seen for
their positive you know
aspect on things and so often we forget
that about individuals with disabilities
the summer shirt project has turned into
a successful year-round business the
company and Jordan are thriving
it feels like nothing short of a miracle
although it's been so much work in the
making and so is shy I was setting out
to create a job for her but she's
happier she is confident you just look
at her and everything about her has
changed I think our story shows never
give up
[Music]
good advice also good advice be kind to
everyone NICE T-Shirts there coming up
meet the woman who saw a complete
stranger stranded in the snow and went
above and beyond to save that stranger's
life
plus our heartwarming videos you know
the ones you gotta see them stick around
welcome back to the uplift and welcome
back to a whole platter of those
heartwarming and delicious videos the
ones you just gotta see and we are going
to start with a bride doing a first look
with her son on her wedding day
[Music]
baby wow
you look so strong
wow you look great baby
wow do you like your suit
you like it
oh amazing
you ready walking down here
I think you could do it
you gonna cry
you need a nap
[Music]
I love you you love mommy yeah give her
a hug
oh
[Music]
happy tears promise you promise
love you so much
oh it's Makai 11 years old uh assuring
his mom yes they were happy tears yes he
is happy very happy for her big day
very sweet story can we top it with our
next video it comes from Brianna Hammond
a recent graduate from the George
Washington University law school who
checked her bar exam results with her
family watching and their reaction says
it all
oh
[Applause]
my God
Brianna hamade Esquire would appear she
is a lawyer now I think she passed that
exam congratulations coming up I set out
to conquer my fears one of the biggest
one step at a time
I want to try to guess what I did
we'll show you plus David begno
introduces us to a woman who saved the
life of a complete and total stranger
one in desperate need of help
what makes you emotional I know we
needed help
and I just kept thinking about what if
it was my family member Christmas wasn't
even about gifts about my kids it wasn't
it was literally him
when a truly massive blizzard hit
Buffalo and residents were urged to stay
indoors one woman found herself looking
outside
what she saw was a stranger who was in
dire need of help she opened her home to
him this is what happened next
is the first time that Yvonne white is
going to see the home where her brother
was treated like family hi
active you saved his life you saved
another human being's life
during the blizzard last month in
Buffalo New York Shakira Autry took
action when others might be less willing
what you did was just beautiful just
beautiful I just did yeah but you know
he made him comfortable he felt the love
he was at my door banging when I woke up
um I Heard help help it was Christmas
Eve Shakira looked out her window and
saw that man struggling in the snow he
keeps screaming oh I don't know what to
do I feel so terrible it was four
degrees outside I can't even walk like
the wind is so bad the wind was gusting
53 miles per hour he had no gloves on
looked lost and in pain
the 35 year old and her boyfriend Trent
alls Jr took him in
64 year old Joey white has the mental
capacity of a 10 year old according to
his sister
he lives in a group home just a few
blocks away from Shakira's home that
morning Joey left home headed for a
movie theater where he's worked as a
custodian for 40 years
is unclear how long he lingered in the
cold he was so Frozen his clothing was
completely froze what were his fingers
like they weren't it was bobbed up with
the bag in his hand I told him I walked
him through I said I have to cut the bag
because the bag was froze he had ice
literally ice balls around his hand
after bandaging his severely frostbitten
hands Shakira called 9-1-1 again and
again but the weather conditions made it
impossible for First Responders to reach
them I was waiting for the National
Guards and I still was waiting for 9-1-1
paramedics fired I was waiting for
anybody and nobody ever came
as the hours passed the snow just kept
piling up so Joey spent Christmas with
Shakira Trent and their kids
she did his laundry
fed him even played movies for him we
got to get some help all the while his
hands were literally changing color and
the pain was becoming unbearable I was
thinking
if there's going to take them this long
to come and get him yeah and he's alive
how long is it going to take him to come
and get a dead body if he was to pass I
couldn't wrap my head around I I just
couldn't do it this young man's fingers
is going to fall off on Christmas night
she turned to social media panicking I
had to use this to cut the ring off of
his finger I'm not no surgeon I'm I'm
right here Joe about 36 hours after
their ordeal began I think these men for
helping two Good Samaritans answered her
plea yeah we all love you we right here
which you hear me because what you tell
me I'm your friend right we're friends
right we're friends forever and
to the hospital when I got in the truck
I he told me he was scared and I said
I'm scared too as I'm scared too Joey
and I said you know we got help we're
going to go the doctors are going to
take care of you and then when he told
me he loved me I knew I knew he really
felt safe this man could have died 64
years old could have died outside I
wasn't letting that happen on my watch
and he wasn't gonna die in front of my
kids what do you think the takeaway is I
feel that especially nowadays the way
our country is everything is just you
know the weather is terrible this is
terrible and then to see the compassion
and the love with two strangers yeah is
is just amazing so you tell me where the
connection is it's here it's it's it's
not here Bingo career
we got him to the emergency room in the
spirit of that first Christmas more than
2 000 years ago
Shakira Autry made room in her home
and in her heart for that Stranger in
need I'm right here when you think back
on it all
what makes you emotional I know he
needed help
and I just kept thinking about what if
it was my family member Christmas wasn't
even about gifts about my kids it wasn't
it was literally him Christmas was him
he was a very good Christmas gift and
now for the rest of my life I will
remember him what would you say to
people watching this who will encounter
something down the road
people should be kind
be loving
we'll take a lesson from you so thank
you you're welcome
thank you both that's a very moving
piece coming up you will finally at long
last see the glory and the mortification
of my attempt to conquer a very big fear
it's not an exercise class although it
looks like one was I successful you will
be the judge and we will show you after
the break
recently my CBS mornings co-anchors and
I set out to conquer our fears mine was
a biggie something I had harbored since
I was a kid but I got a little
professional help with it not the kind
you're thinking of and I took the steps
literally to finally overcome it
Joan Baez the idea of dancing on camera
even with you Joan
too much for me go like this and that's
James Brown not gonna happen Sam
Rockwell I think what's being revealed
here is that you in fact you have a
talent for dancing
and I do not dj D nice joins us on the
turntables here into my eyes America I
am not a dancer see dancing brings out
anxiety and stress
me personally and I think other people
feel uncomfortable too when I start
dancing so you can imagine how I felt
hi Jess
walking into a dance lesson don't you
can't go you can't go a session with
Jessica Castro so nice to meet you she's
danced with some of the biggest names in
music appeared in hit movies and taken
on some of the other hard cases in
choreography for cbs's Come Dance With
Me I hear that you wanna dance I don't
really want to do
a quick read of my contract
then I have to try to dance do you trust
me
I I you know I'm gonna do my best
[Music]
football as a way in
and I didn't always love the process
[Music]
now point to the people no I can't
believe it
oh
yeah
you know what dance is honestly dance is
confidence
you know what does not
confidence step right
this way this way step right seeing
yourself in the mirror looking like this
party starter yes no no yes yes
hands up in the air
before long though I did begin to
understand the basics when you feel like
you're getting lost in the sauce yeah
hey just take it in Relax The Groove the
double balance the step touch right the
Grapevine and The Rock oh my God Tony
this was so good I think I had fun
[Music]
asked me to practice some more at home
and I did
but I kept thinking about a day one
problem an issue far bigger than where
to put my feet you hear that beat no I
hear
the heartbeat I often could not find the
beat come bring your hand here even when
I was literally feeling it feel that
vibration sort of a problem we would
have to address right away on day two I
think the fundamental challenge for me
is not the movement it's not the grace
of it it's not the pace it's I don't
hear music properly for days right I
Hear lyrics and I follow them I don't
hear beat don't get ahead of the beat as
I search for any sort of Rhythm on that
second day it's like a stamp six seven
eight one
I also thought a lot about walking out I
feel like I have a childhood ear injury
but Jessica would not walk out on me you
see the tapping that you're doing with
your feet that's it eventually she got
my attention again with some moves to
help me impress Katie
I love my way that's right there you go
her enthusiasm lifted mine and as our
last Training Day came to a close we're
good some parting advice instead of
looking down and seeing the dance in
your head
come up with it
and just trust
and what we've worked on okay
[Music]
but come Friday night what I honestly
felt was fear
and the hope that something would save
me from embarrassing myself inside this
New York City nightclub we have a couple
more minutes for that blackout come on
New York City turn on your AC's
dance is all about what attitude and
confidence that's right
and we have that tonight
yeah yeah we got it
at least Katie was confident I think he
might have a couple moments the guy is a
college baseball player he's very
coordinated he's a graceful man believe
it or not here we go and once the music
started to play I realized something I
probably should have when I was 17.
foreign
a good night of dancing is not about the
moves
it's about the feeling
and the friends
who in this case dropped by unexpectedly
[Music]
on a scale of one to ten considering
where he started I'm gonna give him an
11. I'm not that I'm a tougher grader
I agree on you're grading on the curve
clearly
he wasn't trying to be a professional
dancer no he just wanted to have fun
what do you give him I would give him a
nine Hey Nobody's Perfect
not bad for a former Wallflower
[Music]
look into my eyes America I am now
apparently yep a dancer and that is our
show I hope it brightened your day
lifted you up it did for me I'm gonna go
look for some more good news see you
next time
foreign